In this and in the remaining lessons for
the course, we turn our attention to
the study of polynomial algorithms.
First however, a little perspective.
In the beginning of the course,
we defined the general
notion of a language.
Then we began to distinguish
between decidable languages and
undecidable ones.
Remember that there were uncountably
many undecidable ones, but
only a countably many decidable ones.
In comparison, the decidable ones should
be infinitesimally small, but I'll give
them this big circle here anyway,
because they're so interesting to us.
In the section of
the course on complexity,
we considered several subclasses
of the decidable languages.
P, which consists of those languages
decidable in polynomial time.
NP, which consists of those languages
that can be verified in polynomial time.
And within this we have this little
bend of NP complete problems,
which are the hardest problems in NP.
If any one of these turned out to be
polynomial, then P would expand and
swallow all of NP.
Or equivalently, we can think of NP
collapsing down into this class P.
In this section,
we're going to focus on this class P,
the set of polynomially
decidable languages.
The overall tone here will hopefully
feel a little more optimistic.
In the previous sections of the course,
many of our results were
of a negative nature.
No, you can't decide that language, or
no that problem isn't trackable
unless P is equal to NP.
Here, the results will
be entirely positive.
No longer we'll be the excluding
problems from a good class.
We'll just be showing the problems
are in this good class, P.
Yes, you can do that in polynomial time
or it's even a low order polynomial, and
we can solve huge instances in practice.